[Music]  Hilary Clinton as I mentioned is in the  news last night she gave an exclusive  interview to ABC's Diane Sawyer in part  to reassure voters that she's in good  health  well I watched the interview I don't  think Hillary Clinton exactly filled me  with confidence  next to Diane Sawyer's exclusive  interview with former Secretary of State  Hillary Clinton making headlines tonight  Diane asking about medical issues after  Republican strategist Karl Rove  suggested she may have suffered  traumatic brain damage after a fall in  2012 how was your health it's very good  thank you how serious was it it was you  know it was about I think a serious  concussion but we're at something with  vision because of the first day of the  fall I had to I had double vision so no  wandering of no lingering effects  it's gonna be fine  she seems fine I wish I could do that I  know she can control one of those cat  clods I just think how that's gonna  throw Putin off yeah